we would now like to discuss drag forces
in a fluid now remember that fluids can
be both a liquid or air and drag forces
are actually quite complicated depending
on a lot of factors if we had an object
falling in a fluid the drag forces can
depend on that both the properties of
the object and in that case it might be
the speed or the size or the shape of
the object and it also can depend on the
properties of the fluid it can depend on
the density of the fluid it can depend
on a property that measures the
resistance of the fluid something which
will refer to as viscosity and also a
property about the compressibility of
the fluid so in general this is quite
complicated and this is done empirically
there's a few very special cases that
we'll discuss that can be solved it
exactly now let's begin our modeling by
considering what we call air drag now in
air drag objects that are moving and
we'll consider objects that are moving
rapidly so our objects are moving very
fast now in that case we can model a
make a rough model of the air drag as
follows the magnitude of this force is
going to be proportional to the speed
squared there'll be a factor where it's
the cross-sectional area that the object
presents in the motion perpendicular to
the plane of motion it can depend on the
density of the air and traditionally
there are a couple of coefficients in
here that are dimensionless that are
empirically determined by the shape of
the object and that's called the drag
coefficient and in fact there's also a
factor 1/2 in the way this law is
traditionally written so what we have
here is a resistive force which is
proportional to the speed squared
and depends on the properties of the air
the density of the air and some physical
parameter properties of the object
itself
now this drag coefficient we can have a
table that can represent that and you
can see here that for a variety of
different shapes the drag coefficient is
somewhere on the order of one so this is
an example of what we refer to as air
drag when we drop objects in a fluid at
very slow speeds we have a different
effect than what we talked about air
drag for example if we drop a marble in
molasses and drop the same marble in
water we see a very different motion and
that depends on a property the fluid
which will refer to as viscosity now
will denote that a coefficient of
viscosity by the symbol end ADA
now when we drop an object into fluid
that the drag force in magnitude will be
proportional to both viscosity will be
proportional to the speed and it will be
proportional to the viscosity and now
for various special cases so for the
special case which is a sphere of radius
R if you study fluid dynamics you can we
can get an exact solution for this drag
force and we'll describe that as it's
going to be opposite the direction of
the velocity so there's a minus sign
there turns out to be some coefficients
six pi times the viscosity of the fluid
times the radius of the sphere and this
particular law which will known as
Stokes law is exactly applicable to the
motion of a sphere now in fact
by experimental measurement this is a
method for D
terminate ADA experimentally by dropping
objects spheres in various different
media with different viscosities so we
can use this to experimentally determine
the viscosity of the media and what's
important to realize too is that this is
applicable to many different examples